now to the latest on covet and the
continuing fight worldwide there the U.S
is restarting a program to send free
covet tests to households after a jump
in new cases here but there is a much
larger covet spread going on right now
in China in fact it's keeping a lot of
people at home even though the
government has loosened its covert
restrictions Elizabeth Palmer has more
good morning China is now facing its
biggest Public Health Challenge since
the start of the pandemic
is spreading like wildfire in China nine
days after the government abruptly
stopped Mass testing and forcible
quarantine measures the who said had
stopped working anyway the explosion of
cases in China is not due to the lifting
of covert restrictions the explosion of
cases of China had started long before
any easing of the zero covered policy if
so no one had told the Chinese public at
clinics like this one in Beijing people
feeling under the weather wait and worry
for three years they've been told that
covid-19 was a killer now the official
line is unless you're really sick just
stay home
it's quite a U-turn reinforced by upbeat
State messaging urging people to get
back to normal but beijingers aren't
buying it empty streets and businesses
show their opting for Extreme Caution I
have to be more careful now says Liu
because no one else is going to protect
me
on a visit to beijing's main hospital
China's kovitz are Sunshine Lan said the
priority is treatment as the government
admitted it had stopped counting cases
and would focus on vaccinations
the protests that erupted across China
at the end of November probably nudged
the state away from its zero coveted
controls along with bad economic data
but a looming tsunami of infection may
have been the Clincher and this is just
the beginning a new study partly funded
by China's Center for Disease Control
warns that the country has to urgently
roll out vaccines and antiviral
medication if it's to avoid a million
coveted deaths for CBS mornings I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo
still dealing with covid three years
later here we go